i remember he had a knife in his right
hand so i said to myself
when i turn around
i'm going to try to deflect the knife
by doing that
as i've done that
he took a step back i just went bang in
my neck
[Music]
so i grew up in tottenham um that's the
north london area
my mum was always around
my dad was there um i had a lot of
brothers a lot of sisters my friends
that i grew up with you know
like a lot of them was into
you could call the bad boy lifestyles
you know what i mean like it's it's no
secret like i rented the best of them i
went in again but
i'd hang around with a whole lot of gang
members like that was no secret
so tell me about that first stabbing
then
my sister phone and she's crying and i
was like what's wrong with this
and she's like she started to explain
that her and her boyfriend like had an
argument that got kind of physical i
must have went down to a place in
tottenham called broad farm i'm just a
young guy you know um i come from a big
family
i've never lost a fight i'm not a bully
by the same time i'm going to defend my
sister right
so as i've got in the car
he pulled out his gun
and i've walked up to method
you're going to shoot me and live with
that bro
he put the gun back in his waist and
what i've done i've literally
so you can imagine he's got a gun in his
waist i put my hand over the gun and
kind of latched my finger into his
trousers like that and held it like that
so i know there's no way he can move
that gun and i was in his face and was
just talking i'm saying brother if you
wanna fight someone fight me
and then at that time my friend has been
in jail for like
i don't know he's in jail for a lot of
years
i had farin and i turned around i saw my
friend i was like yo what's going on and
like i embraced him to say hi
and then about 30 seconds after i had oy
i got stabbed in my chest where my heart
would have been under my arm
you know i mean it was like places where
there's vital organs in my belly so
i believe that he had intentions to
really hurt me
why did you not report it to the police
um
i'd be real
the police are something i've never done
in terms of reporting stuff you know and
i'm i've grown up on the streets in it
my family's from the streets i run the
streets like i've still got bad
boyfriends you know what i mean
but
it's just it just weren't a part of who
i was like to call police um
i needed a family they knew me we came
to our arrangements everything settled
down and
that that's the end of it
could you now talk about the second time
i got a phone call from my girlfriend
and she's like
i could just hear a lot of commotion in
the background she basically said she's
going to a location and
a guy here so
i went back to the to find my girlfriend
so
i got back there
and the person i hit her was just
standing there like he'd done nothing
wrong so i've confronted him i said
brother like why are you hitting my
girlfriend for
and then basically um me and him got
into her old occasion
where the fight just a physical fight it
happened in the shop and then um
i remember coming at the shop i went to
the car to get back into the car
and something just said look behind you
i looked behind me and i just saw this
guy without the longest kitchen i just
remember it like a big silver kitchen
there i remember him chasing me so i
started to run around the car running
around the car trying to get away from
him so every time i got to one side of
the car he was kind of like on the next
side of the car with the knife
and i was like damn and then he opened
the car door
and at that time he opened a car door
to where my misses were sitting so i'm
like done
now he's
going towards her knife
at that time so i've jumped back over
towards the car to start firing him
again to defend there and i remember he
had a knife in his right hand so i said
to myself
when i turn around
i'm going to try to deflect the knife
by doing that
as i've done that
he took a step back i just went bang in
my neck
it felt like a circuit broke
i had a big flash of wire i went
and turned my edge ringing
[Music]
i think i was going on
after that
as soon as you've done that my arm just
dropped to the side boom
and then he's come at me and he started
stabbing me again
and then he stabbed me and he stabbed me
and i fell on the floor this when he
stabbed me across my chest here after me
so the first dab i got in my neck then
the second stab in my neck and then i
got i'm stabbed in my
i've got a big scar across here stab me
there i believe because i got stabbed
the first time and i had something to
kind of compare it against
i knew that i was already in much more
trouble than the first hair if you know
what i mean um
the blood the pain and
not be able to move my arm
and after that
i went straight from thinking i've been
defeated to
i can hear police sirens yeah so the
policewoman stops me she's like what's
going on with her there's a fight no no
i don't know if i i'm cool
she's like no listen we heard there's a
fight here you're involved cream jacket
and after slack she looked at me she
went
cold red cold red cold red multiple stab
wounds
like my top was just turning red by the
second but i got a cream cream and i
remember my my next car my bed is caught
i'm like everywhere there's a blood just
coming for me now she's like cold red
cold red cold red she put me in the
floor
should i get ambulance and next thing i
remember where they put me in that
ambulance at the first thing i kept
saying to the doctor i can't move my arm
i can't move my arm
why i can't move my arm
they didn't care about that because at
that time i'd already lost 40 percent of
my blood so i did so they were just
trying to stop me from losing blood now
i i just the last thing i remember
hearing was my mom screamed my mum
screamed
and i remember like
trying to like
put myself to have a strong face like
there's nothing wrong with me but
you know that mean my mum in it
and then after that
i just remember waking up two days later
in a hospital so the doctor sat me down
and said to me farron i've got good news
you i've got bad news he said you have
got a severe nerve damage it's been cut
straight through um
but
the good news is i said what's the good
news he said one percent of the whole
human population got your body structure
i said what do you mean you said i have
6.2 billion people only one percent like
you you said your arteries are under
more muscle you have spirits that we can
use and we thought um you've got a heart
rate under 60 beats a minute and we
really do believe that you can have um a
good
recovering rate if we do the surgery
when i do
i'm talking about my arm was dead that i
couldn't remove it that i was getting
i was burning my hand
i'm not really under the next day until
i had blisters that's how bad it was so
i had to build up everything again from
my emotions to my mindset to my physical
that just to get back to where i could
be you know
how long did the rehabilitation tape i'd
say physically
it took the best part of five to ten
years um you know nerves go back a
millimeter a day and
you've got a sister with
diet good diet and sleep and
physiotherapy and
goodwill you know i mean it's not easy
and could you just explain to us how
many times you were stabbed in total oh
so literally um it's weird man because
it's just loads of nines i had nine
children in my family i got stabbed nine
times on one occasion i got stabbed nine
times another occasion um so all
together
i got stabbed 18 times
it'd be great if you could first explain
to me how you kind of started off your
anti-knife crime
so i started to do that little social um
social media vlogs facebook here and
there and it's just me giving advice
about the life i've been through and how
children can avoid getting the same
situation
and
just various little things
and after a while i sat down and i said
to myself you know what i'm sitting down
doing these videos yeah and
all i've got to do is scroll up the
facebook feed and then i'm going to see
something that's being stabbed and
killed i like i just felt like like he
just felt so pointless to me
so i sat down to myself and i thought
how can i
help this situation more
i said okay
if i could take these nights with his
children the way i see it if you ain't
got a knife in here you can't use it
and if any child is going to come to the
point where you're saying you know what
i want to hand you my knife you've
already started a mental transition for
the bell because you're deciding to give
a knife away right so
i i was trying to come up with a way
that'd be beneficial to these kids i
don't really want to be giving people
money for a ramble on f that they're
going to go exchange buy another one or
buy
something silly with you know what i
mean so i said to myself all right then
jd sports vouchers i said what young
child wouldn't want a 20 pound off for
their pair trainers you know what i'm
saying for that random knife that's been
in their house just sitting there the
last four years that no one cares about
so i put it out and literally from 2019
to this day i'm inundated with messages
about collections um
and it's not only the young people
who i started my target audience with
like it's just become like a whole
community thing i've got parents i've
got social workers
i've got children i've got members of
the public stuff and they contact me to
get rid of them
initially how did the police react to
what you were doing
the police react i was getting arrested
i was getting handcuffed i was getting
literally strip searched and everything
at first but i feel like they felt kind
of underminded by what i was doing to an
extent um
i believe they feel their
accountability would be a thing as well
you know if anything did happen you know
you got to think about who's going to
come and do all the problems the police
you know what i'm saying
i've got to the stage where i've built
up
like
enough of a relationship with the
community and the local authorities that
they understand what i'm doing i won't
be arrested when i've got an ass and
i've recently um gone into a weapons
pilot with the local authorities
where um they just make sure that i've
got
a medical kit in a car a phone
and i just report
the area that i'm going they don't want
a direct name they don't want a direct
person they want to know the area
where i picked up from that that the
pickup went well and where i'm dropping
it to and then that's it
how many weapons have you collected
the last check we've done
is just over 1200 swords and lefts
17 axes nunchucks a shotgun two handguns
a replica and two tasers um in terms of
people that message me for collections
man like there's a big variety of them
mothers what i'd say is the young men
first themselves
i've seen so much relief from some of
them you know they've got stuff in their
house
yeah that
they can get in trouble for
that can hurt their son that there's
something getting a lot of trouble for
and when i take it and remove it from
there
the relief from some of them is like it
is a good feeling to know that i'm the
person that done something that they
never had no one else that i could do
how old is the youngest you've collected
a knife from
11
11
a young impulsive naive child who's
driven by social media and materialistic
stuff
gets a knife in his hand
he ain't gonna know
that the severity of stabbing someone
until he's sitting in jail knowing that
he's got another tenure to do
or
he's urinating
through some sort of medical device
or
he's dead
how many weapons are out there on the
street of london
well all i know is that mr putin please
donate up to two tons
a month
of ness
if you want to start adding guns to that
man it's just i don't know what kind of
way it's going to come up
what kind of change are you hoping to
make in the future
i really want to start cracking down in
these schools the first person who's
really on site with someone that's got
stabbed it's going to be that person's
friend a person's family and if you know
that it only takes a matter of minutes
for someone to bleed out depending on
where they've been stabbed and if these
young children are
taught how to um
conduct first aid and
how to put a tourniquet on and things
like that i really do feel like that
could be
like the difference between life and
difference in certain situations
we're just trying to get a lot done in
terms of um
education for the children in schools
but i feel like prevention is better
than cure right now
i work closely with um an organization
called still warriors um
their organization that they take metal
donated from their police in terms of
knives
and then they melt them down at the gyms
for outdoor gyms and i feel like it's
just
like it works you know the nights come
here
from a bad place
and they go there and get melted down
and put into something that's gonna be a
good thing you know so i feel like
that's the full transition there it
works
do you ever get scared of going to
collect these weapons
hey you know what yeah
um
no i don't get scared doing it um
it makes me feel good doing it i journey
for if the community wouldn't support me
and it was i don't feel like i'd be
doing what i'm doing
i sat down and i thought about it
would there be a time when i get a
message and um
someone's hand the knife and then i'll
say
i'm not doing it
and to this day i
just i don't think i can come up with
the excuse or the word no i'm not coming
to get it
what would you tell someone who has a
weapon and is willing to hand it in
contact me hand it in anonymously like
there'll be no problems i'll take the
weapon a few i hand it in and you can be
sure that it's out of your way no longer
a problem and you won't get in trouble
for it
if you carry a knife and you're not
going to have it in just make sure
within the gold jar or you want to die
there's no more to it live by the knife
die about an f it's that symbol
[Music]
so as i reloaded
and
went pointed the gun
is when he jumps in the back of the van
but i ran to the passenger side and then
shot through the passenger side window